valérie je t'aime
hier j'étais vidé j'ai dit qu'ils
étaient une [ __ ] mais en fait c'est pas
vrai
reviens tu es bon en fait t'es pas une
[ __ ] et qu'une [ __ ] mais je t'aime
quand même alors revient bon moi je
n'aime pas dire des messages des mots
que tout le monde comprend donc j'ai
décidé de frein cote d'amour et ça rend
les gens toujours ahuri quand tu
m'entends dire shit et ap xxl et je sais
qu'il n'y a qu'une personne qui la
comprend votre nom s'il vous plaît
catherine à ses superbes catherine
j'aime bien vous voulez pas savoir le
mien par hasard c'est tara c'est bien
non ça va très bien qu'on physiquement
cieux on étant donné que ce tube ou mon
très cher époux
que je vous aime et je ne vous oublie
pas ainsi que bastien jacques martin que
je connais très bien j'aime beaucoup son
édition le jeu vif et bravo à monsieur
jacques martin je souhaite à tous et à
toutes l'ops lors